well new at 11 o'clock just days after  staff at our local thrift shop reported  a burglary  now more items have been stolen from the  store this is happening near decatur and  craig  at dog junkies now the business works  very closely with local rescue group a  home for spot  now the manager says somebody dropped  off donations sunday  while they were closed and this person  came by this morning and they  stole some of it now the stories  actually closed on sundays and monday so  there's no one there to accept the  donations  if you're interested instead you can  call during business hours to set up an  appointment  and someone will meet you they sell  these items so they can help more rescue  groups in town  if you recognize the people though in  those videos please call crime stoppers